le pouvoir taliban doit tenir ses
engagements pour être reconnu par la
communauté internationale
une annonce du kremlin une délégation de
talibans est à mouscou en ce moment pour
une réunion avec des représentants d'une
dizaine de pays dont la chine l'inde et
l'iran verhaeghe hoffman suis sûr pour
nous ce sommet on va la retrouver tout
de suite
verra bonjour alors premières
déclarations donc à l'issue des
pourparlers que peut-on retenir
bonjour saman table la communauté
internationale doit annoncer aux
préjugés se joindre à l'effort pour
aider l'afghanistan sinon il pénalise le
peuple afghan a déclaré l'envoyé spécial
du président russe pour l'afghanistan à
venir cabo love à l'issue des
consultations avec les plans pour la
reconnaissance du
galsi
problèmes de liaison avec vera goffman
je sais pas si on va la retrouver on la
reprend 38 nationale
certainement elle a été soulevée comment
ne pas la soulever mais tout le monde du
moins notre ministre des affaires
étrangères l'a indiqué sans aucun doute
ce moment viendra un jour
il viendra et tout le monde l'a dit à la
délégation afghane quand ils
commenceront à répondre à la plupart des
attentes de la communauté internationale
attendent qu'ils sont liés à des
questions de droits de l'homme et
d'inclusion
plus tôt dans la journée à lors de
l'ouverture du forum les chefs de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov a
souligné qu'il n'existait pas
d'alternative au pouvoir actuel en
afghanistan même s'il ne peut être
considéré comme stable pour le moment je
vous propose d'écouter
le nouvel équilibre des forces qui
s'était établi après le 15 août dernier
fait qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'autre
moyens de discuter même si en même temps
au niveau interne internationale il n'y
a pas de reconnaissance officielle il ya
un certain nombre de problèmes sociaux
culturels
qui se posent et les nouvelles autorités
de kaboul sont confrontés à ces
problèmes ce tout cela montre qu' il est
difficile de qualifier de stable la
situation d'un pays mais on voit un
certain nombre de groupes terroristes
cherchent à utiliser cette situation et
notamment l'état islamique et al qaïda
qui de nouveau tente à relever la tête
et à faire des attaques sanglantes dans
différentes parties du pays sergueï
lavrov a également confirmé que là ça
allait continuer à coopérer avec
l'émirat islamique et a promis un envoi
d d'humanitaires au peuple afghan tout
en appelant la communauté internationale
à faire de même
merci à beaucoup avouent verhaeghe
hoffman pour toutes ces précisions
directeur depuis moscou en russie